hey guys it's me katie and this is
another episode of lost in translation
usually katie puts me in the hot seat
but today it's kelly's turn if your
first time joining us we take a recipe
we put it into google translate we go
from english to french to sudanese to
korean and many many many more until we
bring it back to english to give us this
hilariously translated recipe we have
been planning this four months the whole
team knows we sent an email out her boss
knows and she said and we quote oh my
god i love this so much kelly has no
idea it's been actually really hard to
keep it from her let's go do this
take one
can you try that thing that we just
tried yes
your turn kelly shut up
are you serious
[Music]
nemo did you know yes of course
good luck ready yep
a great idea this is not a great idea
step one cooking plate with a band of
berry trees and fat spray
i'm consuming this
fat and it's spray cooking plate spray a
cookie sheet with spray with a band of
berry trees do i like flour it i'm going
to spray this baking tray with fat spray
band of berries maybe like a bowl but
why wouldn't you just use oil i'm
skipping the berries i don't know what
it
means
i feel like banda berries might be
important and i shouldn't just write it
off so i think i need a hint
already who would you like your hint
from jasmine your cooking plate is not
so simple it might be a more unique
piece of equipment that you see on your
cart here's why maybe i think these we
i've never seen these in the kitchen
before so somebody had to go buy them
your band of berries is still
missing this is the cooking plate we've
helped kelly it's her first time bamboo
leaves band of berries bamboozled
[Laughter]
i've chosen grape leaves based on the
fact that there's two jars and that's
the only reason why usually i'm the one
prepping the food and i'm like laughing
behind the camera feeling confident i'm
gonna spray this with fat spray and line
it with grape leaves
i feel like this is the wrong decision
i feel like i need to change my mind i
grape leaves felt weird i have no idea
what band of berries is i don't think
it's grape leaves so i'm just gonna
leave it i'm gonna scrap it it's gonna
screw me over later
step two add 3 4 cup of dough grim three
tablespoons of sugar three tablespoons
of bees half a teaspoon of flavor until
a soft paste appears in a small bowl
got it
i've got a bowl i know bees
make honey i feel like dough gram is
going to be one of these beans why do
you think that they're here
oh wait a soft paste it's got to be a
flower
i'm gonna just put the bees in first
three tablespoons of bees all-purpose
flour masa it's happy with the starch
you guys are mean three tablespoons of
sugar well i'm just gonna go with sugar
because i know from translating sugar
doesn't really translate it's the same
word in every language and a half a
teaspoon of flavor so i need to make a
paste so it's got to be a flower i'm
gonna go with all purpose because
it can't hurt
it's all purpose
three-fourths cup of dogram flour
this isn't gonna make a paste maybe i
was supposed to do water this is not a
paste i think i should have done the
beans that are soaking in liquid and
then that would have formed a paste we
gave you one mulligan since your first
time go go go go
now which bean i have no idea what these
beans are but i think they're dogram so
i'm going for it and it feels like the
texture of taste three tablespoons of
sugar three tablespoons of bees i'm
sticking with bees is honey and sugar i
don't have a clean thing i'm just gonna
eyeball it three tablespoons half a
teaspoon of flavor my only two flavoring
options are vanilla and pandan and i
know we didn't have pandan in the
culinary kitchen so i feel like it has
to be for today now i have to mash this
into a paste i think this is as paste
like if it's gonna get katie's telling
me i have to move forward so i'm gonna
put this in the fridge and then move to
the next step step three form a moderate
skin swizzle two cups bubble butter
divided one half cup of
that is not english this is english
form a moderate skin swizzle two cups of
bubble butter divided one half cup of
disaccharides two cups of water one
tablespoon of coffee butter and 1 4
teaspoon of fragrant until flawless and
dirty another fragrant form a moderate
skin i feel like that's
to make the dough on moderate heat
because i have to melt bubble butter
that's bubble butter okay let's look for
butter that's a lot of tapioca starch
i feel like that's going to be my flour
bubble butter
bubbly aromatic
airy swizzle swizzle is melt i just keep
thinking like in a pan i'm gonna melt
two cups of bubble butter but what is
bubble butter dice what is that other
word disaccharide disaccharides see i
didn't do well on my sats i don't know
you know the chemical names for things
nope i know i'm using water and it needs
to be evenly combined from a moderate
skin i think that means over moderate
heat i told you guys i can't do this you
can you can do it you can
and you thought two cups was too much
for butter like boba tapioca bubble
butter yes
okay boba is made from tapioca starch
those are the bubble butters and two
cups of flour makes a lot more sense
than two cups of butter disaccharide you
want a hint yeah i need a hand you
really did i have no idea what that
means saccharin
sugar hey i don't have fruit
i only know that from translating the
other recipe i only have one hint left
and i'm on step three two cups of water
i can do that water is universal that
feels good let me get a whisk i feel
better because i've seen jasmine make
boba i think half teaspoon fragrant is
going to be this vanilla because it's
fragrant and it's the only
thing i have left it didn't say what to
do i'm assuming i didn't just stir it
because it's already clumping and the
coffee butter maybe oil but i don't see
any oil or the only oil i see is like
canola or vegetable i'm just gonna add
it i'm gonna do half what it says
because i don't know if it's right
that's the way the recipe works all
right this has gotten very thick and
gelatinous it's not very well combined
which i know was
supposed to be flawless and flirty this
is very flawed
and dull step four wake up to a large
mixture and cook over low heat well i've
been doing high heat
maybe that's why it's
not flirty step five turn off the oven
and continue to bake until the dough
begins to separate on both sides of the
mold that's what i just said it's like
totally clearing from the pan oh my god
it's one ball
wow jasmine doesn't look like
wow that's how i talk to my kids i'm
like wow
oh wait i was supposed to remove from
the oven cut this turn off the oven and
continue to bake until the dough begins
to separate on both sides of the mold so
we're there step six add meaty fillets
and learn to communicate did my husband
write learn to communicate
[Laughter]
add meanie fillets
this is sweet coconut meat coconut meat
and learn to communicate and fold to
combine now which one
i have shredded or large flakes i'm
gonna go with large flakes because it's
meatier
i switched my mind from super meaty to
like medium meaty so it incorporates
better it didn't tell me an amount so
i'm just gonna guess it's not
incorporating any more but it's giving
it a nice layer a nice coating and i
think that's the best i can do so let's
go to the next step convene cut a spoon
bunch of flour with kitchen scissors
put one of them on the floor of the oven
cup convene from what i'm doing remove
it put it here cut some off and put them
in here but how much all right i'm just
going to cut it i just cut off a ball
i'm just going to keep filling these
because i'm confident woman are you
feeling good how are you feeling
so i'm just going to keep filling these
cups with a couple spoons of this dough
until they're all done add one food to a
server and a tablespoon of flour on top
i'm a confident woman
and i feel great about getting my paste
out and seeing what i can do here
so what i think i'm doing is putting
some of this here and then adding more
dough on top and sealing it in i
apologize for whatever recipe this is
i'm not trying to do it injustice but
it's katie and jasmine's fault
i think jasmine's a genius after being
in these shoes like her word association
is so
good and i'm like how does she know that
it's because she did well in her sats
so i added one food to server i'm just
assuming this dough is that got
translated to flour step nine fill a
bowl with flour return the rest i think
that meant what i just did number ten
add water to the central pan and rupture
slightly put a bucket on it so they are
steamed i think what this means is fill
a pot with water until it's rapidly
boiling and put a steamer basket on top
so i've added water to the central pan
and i'm going to let it rupture rapidly
and then i'm going to put this bamboo
bucket on top step 11 put the flowers in
a basket with a lid cover with a fork
for 15 minutes and the buns will be
light and shiny we're calling these
flowers cover with a fork a fork is a
lid why is a fork a lid i don't know i'm
gonna put the flowers in here and stain
them for 15 minutes this is rupturing
slightly i'm going to add my flowers
and it says to
it doesn't say steam but cook them until
the buns are shiny
and light 15 minutes what do you think
shiny and light means shiny and light so
i'll come back in 15 minutes and then
we'll move on to the next step
these have been steaming for 15 minutes
let's see if they are light and shiny oh
i feel like i over filled the bottom
layer when i was cutting the pieces i
wasn't like thinking about presentation
and i should have like this guy's just
like about to jump off the cliff he's
like i'm done step 12 draw a 10 inch
square piece of plastic paper on a flat
surface
separate the abracadabra in the middle
of the plastic
parchment my bamboo baby separate the
abra cadabra in the middle of the
plastic it's not like what a magician
says i need a hint i need it you want it
you're fine
final hint sometimes a magician says
this word before they open a door
open sesame
[Music]
don't genie say that not magicians
magical people 10 inch piece of classic
paper so plastic didn't translate i'm
assuming i'm just guessing i know
there's sesames involved because genies
say it
not magicians and
so i'm gonna roughly make a ten inch
square of plastic
wrap so separate the abercrdaba in the
middle of the plastic so i'm just going
to sprinkle the abracadabra
in the middle
step 13 with the help of the banana
master take some of the food out of the
pot and put it on the hammer so i was
supposed to use the banana leaves with
the help of the banana master i didn't
need the banana master's help take some
of the food out of the pot and put it on
the hammer
step 14.
put the my leaf cake in a plastic bag to
cover papa
pack your present leftovers are all the
same leftovers are all the same means do
it with the rest hammer was i just like
pound it
there's no more i can do here honestly
all i think is like keep coating these
in
sesame seeds and then cover with plastic
i'm gonna get one more sheet of plastic
to wrap it to cover papa i'm covering
papa and then it's just telling me to
store it but i don't know how it's
supposed to be stored so i'm just gonna
coat the rest of these with the sesame
seeds wrap them up like a present and
then read the next step i've already
tasted each element and it tastes really
good i just think i have the visual off
which as the food stylist is really sad
leave the bread for 20 minutes okay
leave it they do feel warm so i'm
wondering if leave the bread for 20
minutes means like chill it so i'm gonna
go pop these in the fridge for 20
minutes i don't know if it's right but
then we'll read our final step
open the cake and give it here
open the cake i think that means take
these out of the plastic wrap and then
give it to my friends
i think it's time to see great idea in
real life
open your eyes
oh
[Laughter]
my god these are so cute and the color
is way better i would like to know what
these are called so this is called
buying suse it is a vietnamese dessert
also known as a conjugal cake it's
traditionally served at vietnamese
weddings and the stickiness signifies
the stickiness in marriage oh that's so
cute
definitely did too many sesame seeds i'm
just noticing a lot of differences
cheers to a great idea
there's a lot of music i love the inside
i don't like how many sesame seeds are
put on but this bean paste is so good
cheers
the paste is good to be honest it tastes
really similar this tastes close to the
real thing it's just a lot of sesame
seeds the texture on this is better it's
really good
i feel like this is my boss
all right let's try the real one
this is way better there's no comparing
like
no this is incredible it's sweet but not
too sweet the coconut is incorporated
this is amazing these are both really
good but the original is definitely
better no contest all i have to say is
i'm coming for you ladies you're up next
this was so much fun a lot harder than i
could have ever expected and if you guys
have any ideas how i can get back at
katie and jasmine shoot me a dm and we
will get the ball rolling bye
bye bye
[Music]
oh yes
you